Mourning the victims, and searching for answers
in Christchurch.
Outside the city's al-Noor Mosque, people
paused to honor those who lost their lives
in the worst mass murder in New Zealand's
modern history.
These were the scenes Friday, as a suspected
white supremacist opened fire on worshippers
at al-Noor, and at a Mosque in the neighborhood
of Linwood, killing and wounding dozens.
As police scrambled to stop the shooter, rescuers
raced to save the wounded.
Survivors spoke of a narrow escape.
After three or four minutes we heard you know,
the firing, and it was from the main entrance,
the main entrance of the building, and then
everybody just run towards the back doors
just to save themselves.
First we hide behind cars, you know under
the car, and we see the firing still on we
tried to jump the fence.
This footage shows the moment police apprehended
the suspect, after forcing his car off the
road; they brought an end to the rampage.
The suspected shooter is 28-year-old Australian
Brenton Tarrant.
Charged with murder, he appeared for the first
time in court on Saturday and was remanded
to custody until April 5.
Investigators say he published a racist, anti-immigrant
'Manifesto' online before carrying out the
massacre.
Prime Minister Jacinda Ardern vowed to tighten
the country's gun laws, after it was revealed
Tarrant had a license to carry the types of
guns used in the attack.
"While work is being done as to the chain
of events that led to both the holding of
this gun license, and the possession of these
weapons, I can tell you one thing right now
- our gun laws will change."
After the attack, New Zealand's terror alert
level was raised from low to high, with added
security around the country's Mosques.
Dozens of the wounded remain hospitalized,
some of whom are still
fighting for their lives.